spend sometimes like two months training
the Bots
um
uh on thousands of CPUs
um terabytes of memory sometimes uh but
when it came time to actually play
against the humans they would act almost
instantly it was just a lookup table
um and the humans when they were in a
tough spot they would not act instantly
they would think they would sit there
and they would think for five seconds
maybe five minutes if it was a really
difficult decision and it was clear that
was allowing them to come up with better
strategies
and so I wanted to investigate this
behavior in our Bots like if we could
add this to our Bots how much of a
difference would it make the ability to
instead of acting instantly to take some
time and compute a better strategy for
the spot that it the the agent was in
and this is what I found
so on the x-axis here we have like the
number of
buckets the number you can think of this
as like number of parameters in your
model and on the y-axis we have distance
from Nash equilibrium so this is
basically like how much you would lose
to worst case adversary so the lower the
lower this number is the better your
pokerbot is
and you can see as you scale the number
of parameters your performance improves
and it you know as as you increase the
number of parameters by about 100 full
100x
um you know your exploitability goes
down by about half and indeed you're
getting a much better poker bot
but you can see the blue line here is if
you don't have search and the orange
line is if you do add search
and you can see just adding search
adding the ability to sit there and
think for a bit improve the performance
of these models
um it like it reduced the exploitability
the distance from Nash equilibrium by
about 7X
and if you were to extend that blue line
and see how how many parameters would
you need in order to
um be comparable to adding search the
answer is you would need to scale up
your model by about a hundred thousand X
so this was pretty mind-blowing to me
when I saw this I mean over the course
of my PhD the first three years three
first three or four years of my PhD I
managed to scale up
um these models by about 100x
um
and I was proud of that I mean that's
like a pretty
pretty impressive result I think but
what this plot was showing me was that
just adding search
was the equivalent of scaling things up
by about a hundred thousand X and so all
of my previous research up until this
point
would just be a footnote compared to
adding search
so when I saw this it became clear this
this was the answer to beating top
humans in poker and so for the next year
basically non-stop I worked on scaling
search
um now there's a question that naturally
comes up which is why wasn't this
considered before
um there's a few factors so first of all
I should say like the search had been
considered in poker before and it's
actually quite natural to say like well
you know if you had search in chess and
search and go like why would you not
consider searching poker
um there's a few reasons one is that
culturally like the poker research grew
out of Game Theory and reinforcement
learning and so it wasn't really from
the same background as like the people
are working on chess and working on go
um when you scale search scaling test on
compute it makes all your experiments
much more expensive and just like more
unpleasant to work with
um and there were just like incentive
structures I mean people were always
thinking about winning the next annual
computer poker competition and the acpc
limited the resources that you could use
at test time so search wasn't really
possible effectively in the acpc
um and I think the biggest factor is
that people just didn't think it would
make such a huge difference I mean I
think it's reasonable to look at
something like search and think like oh
yeah that might make like a 10x
difference yeah you probably want to
think it makes a hundred thousand X
difference
um and so there were some people working
on it but it wasn't really the focus of
a lot of people's research
so anyway
um focused on scaling search and that
led to the 2017 brains versus AI
competition where we again played our
bot against four top Poker Pros
um 120 000 uh hands of poker 200 000 in
prize money and this time the bot won by
15 big blinds per hundred instead of
nine big blinds per hundred
this was a crushing Victory um each
human lost individually to the bot and
um
four standard deviations of statistical
significance
um we followed this up in 2019 with uh
six player poker AI competition
um the big difference here is that we
figured out how to do depth limited
search so before in the 2017 bot it
would always have the search to the end
of the game
um here it only had to do search a few
moves ahead and could stop there
and so this time
um again it went with statistical
significance and what's really
surprising about this bot is that
despite it being a much larger game uh
the six player Pokemon pluribus cost
under 150 to train on
um cloud computing resources and it runs
on 28 CPU cores at inference time
there's no gpus
so I think what this shows is that
um this really was an algorithmic
improvement I mean this would have been
doable 20 years ago if if people knew
how to do it
um and I think it also shows the power
of search you know if you can figure out
how to scale uh that compute at test
time it really can make a huge
difference and bring down your your
training costs by a huge amount
um
okay anyway yeah so I want to say also
this is not limited to Poker uh if you
look at go you see a similar pattern so
this is a plot from the alphago zero
paper
on the x-axis we have different versions
of alphago and on the y-axis we have ELO
reading which is a way of comparing
different Bots but also a way of
comparing Bots to humans and you can see
if
uh okay so superhuman performance is
around 3 600 kilo
and you can see alphago Lee the version
that played against Lisa doll in 2016
that's right over the line of superhuman
performance alphago zero the strongest
version of alphago is around 5200 ELO
but if you take out the test time search
if you just play according to the policy
net and not do any Monte College
research in alphago zero at test time
then the ELO rating drops to around
three thousand which is substantially
below expert human performance
okay so what this shows is that if you
take out montegolet research at test
time
the alphago zero is not superhuman and
in fact nobody has made a superhuman
Gobot that does not use search in some
form nobody has made a raw neural
network that can be top humans in go
and I should say also this is just if
you're taking out the search at test
time I'm I'm not even talking about
taking it out of training time if you
took it out of trains I wouldn't even
get off the ground
now there's a question of like okay well
surely you could just scale up the model
scale up the matter training and you
would eventually you know surpass
superhuman performance and and match the
performance if you added search and
that's true yes if you scale up the
models and if you scale up the training
um then you would eventually match the
performance with search but there's a
question of like how much would you have
to scale It Up by
now a rough rule of thumb is that in
order to increase your ELO rating by
about 120 points you either have to
double the amount of model size and
training or you have to double the
amount of test time search
and so if you look at that gap of around
2 000 ELO points um and you calculate
the number of deadlines that you would
need the answer is that in order to get
the raw policy net from 3000 ELO to 5200
ELO you would need to scale your model
and your training by about a hundred
thousand X
okay
um so so why is why is this important
I think you look at what's happening
today with large language models and
Transformers and and you see something
similar I mean you're getting
huge uh there's a question of like what
do I mean by search
um
there's uh specific kinds of search like
multicolage research the ability to just
like plan ahead what you're going to do
instead of just like acting instantly
um based on your pre-computed policy but
really what I mean by search more
broadly is the ability to scale the
amount of computation to get better
performance
um I think that's the real value of that
search is adding instead of just like
acting according to your precomputed
you know front loading all of your
computations so you're doing everything
all your computation ahead of time and
then like at inference time acting
basically instantly
could you get a better solution if you
had five minutes to Output an action
instead of 100 milliseconds
so
yeah I think you look at um
I'm sorry there's a there's a question
uh does a Transformer with a search
circuit count a search or do you mean
hand engineering search Algos
um I don't want to get bogged down into
like the details of like how to do this
uh because like the the answer is nobody
really knows yet um nobody really has a
general way of doing search and all the
domains that we've done search
successfully like poker and go it
started a fairly domain specific way
um you know go use this algorithm called
multicolage research
um
and yeah I guess you could think of beam
search as like one simple performance
search but you know it does seem like
there should be better better ways
um in the future
so anyway um where I'm going with this
is like you look at
actually Which models are being trained
today and you know you're seeing
millions of dollars being thrown at
pre-training like
I want to be surprised if we see a uh
you know a large language model that
would cost like 100 million dollars to
train
um we might even get to a billion
dollars
but
the inference cost is still going to be
very small
and so there's a question of like could
you do substantially better if you could
scale the amount of inference cost as
well
maybe that could like amortize uh some
of your training costs
okay so there's this uh
there's this lecture called The Bitter
Lesson by Richard Sutton uh that says
the biggest lesson that can be learned
and so it's a really great essay I
recommend reading it but one of the big
takeaways is like he says the biggest
lesson that can be learned from over 70
years of AI research is that General
methods that leverage computation are
ultimately the most effective
the two methods that seem to scale
arbitrarily in this way are search and
learning
now I think we've done a great job with
um generalizing search sorry
generalizing learning and I think that
there's still room for improvement when
it comes to search
um and yeah the next goal really is
about generality like can we develop a
truly General way of scaling inference
compute instead of just doing things
like Monte College research that are
specific to a better domain to a
specific domain and also better than
things like Chain of Thought
um what this would look like is that you
have much higher test time compute
but you have much more capable models
and I think for certain domains that
trade-off is worth it like if you think
about what inference costs we're willing
to pay for a proof of the Riemann
hypothesis I think we'd be willing to
pay a lot
or you know the cost of
what cost do we want to pay for new
life-saving drugs I think we'd be
willing to pay a lot
so I think that there is an opportunity
here
okay anyway so that's my Prelude I guess
any questions about that before I move
on to Cicero
by the way the reason why I'm talking
about this is because it's going to
inform
the approach that we took to Cicero
which I think is quite different from
the approach that a lot of other
researchers might have taken to this
problem
um someone asked can you give an example
of search well Monte Carlo research is
one form of search you could also think
of like
um breadth first search uh depth
research these kinds of things they're
all search
um I would also argue that like Chain of
Thought is doing something similar to
search where it's it's allowing the
model to like Leverage extra compute at
test time to get better performance
um
but I think that that's that's the main
thing that you want the ability to like
Leverage extra compute at test time
uh what's the search what's the space
that you are searching over
um again like in in a game like go it's
like different board positions but you
could also Imagine searching over like
you know different sentences that you
could say things like that
um
there's there's a lot of flexibility
there as well
okay so now I want to get into cereal
um so first thing I should say when it
comes to Cicero this is
um
a big team effort
this was like this is actually one of
the the great things about working on
this project that there was just such a
diverse talent pool
um experts in reinforcement learning
planning Game Theory natural language
processing all working together on this
um and it would not have been possible
without without everybody
so the motivation for diplomacy actually
came from 2019 we were looking at all
the breakthroughs that were happening at
the time and I think a good example of
this is this XKCD comic that came out in
um that shows like different categories
games games that are solved games where
computers can be top humans games where
computers to loose top humans and games
where computers may never out play top
humans
and in this category computers still
lose the top UNC had four games go arima
poker and Starcraft
um in 2015
uh actually one of my colleagues David
Wu made the first day out of b top
humans in arima in 2016 we have alphago
beating Lisa doll and go in 2017 you
have the work that I just described
where we beat top humans in poker and in
2019 we had um Alpha star beating expert
humans in Starcraft
so that shows the incredible amount of
progress that had happened in strategic
reasoning over the past several years uh
leading up to 2019. and at the same time
we also had gpt2 come out in 2019 and it
showed that language model like in
natural language processing was
progressing much faster than I think a
lot of people including us expected
and so we were thinking about what after
um the six player poker work I was
discussing with my colleagues what
should we work on next
and we were throwing around like
um different domains to work on and
given the incredible amount of progress
in AI we wanted to pick something really
ambitious something that we thought
you couldn't just Tackle by scaling up
the existing approaches that you really
needed to something to do in order to
address
and we landed on diplomacy because we
thought that it would be the hardest
game to make an AI for
so what is diplomacy
um diplomacy is a natural language
strategy game
um it takes place uh right before World
War One you play as one of the seven
Great powers of Europe uh England France
Germany Austria Russia and Turkey and uh
your goal is to control a majority of
the map
um in practice that really happens like
if you control a majority of majority of
the map than you've won in practice
um Nobody ends up winning outright and
so your score
is proportional to the percentage of the
map that you control
now what's really interesting about
diplomacy is that it is a natural
language negotiation game
um so you have these conversations like
what you're seeing here between Germany
and England where they will privately
communicate with each other before
making their moves and so you can have
Germany ask like want to support Sweden
England says let me think on that
um and and so on
so this is a popular strategy game uh
developed in the 1950s
um it was JFK and Kissinger's favorite
game actually
and like I said each third involves
sophisticated that private natural
language negotiations and I want to make
clear like this is not
negotiations like you would see in a
game like Catan for example you're
seeing
it's it's much more like um Survivor if
you've ever seen a TV show Survivor
um you have discussions around like
alliances that you'd like to build
um discussions around like specific
tactics that you'd like to execute on
the current track
um and also you know like more long-term
strategy
um around like where do we go from here
and how do we divide resources
now
the way the game works you have these
things that last between 5 and 15
minutes depending on the on the version
of the game
um and then on each term and all these
negotiations are done privately
otherwise negotiation also I think that
you are not muted okay thank you
um
and then after the negotiation period
completes everybody will simultaneously
write down their moves and so a player
could promise you something like I'm
going to support you into this territory
this turn
um but then when people actually write
down their moves they might not write
that down and so you only find out if
they were true to their word when all
the moves are revealed simultaneously
uh and so for this reason alliances and
Trust building is key the ability to
trust that somebody's going to follow
through on their promises that's really
what this game is all about and the
ability to convince people that you are
going to follow through on your promises
is really what this game is all about
and so for this reason diplomacy has
long been considered a challenge problem
for AI there's research in the game
going back to the 80s the research
really only picked up
it's it picked up like quite intensely
in starting in 2019 when researchers
from demide ourselves Mila
um other places uh started working on
this
now a lot of that research the vast
majority of that research actually was
focused on the non-leverage version of
the game which was seen as a stepping
stone to the full natural language
version though we decided to focus from
the start on the full natural language
version of the game
so to give you a like what this
is a dialogue look like
here is one example so here
um England you can see they moved their
Fleet in Norway to St Petersburg and
that occupies the Russian territory
and so this is what the board state
looks like after that move and now
there's this conversation between
Austria and Russia Austria says well
what happened up north in Russia says
England stabbed I'm afraid the end may
be close for me and my friend Oscar says
yeah that's rough are you going to be
okay up there Russia says I hope so
England seems to still want to work
together Austria says can you make a
deal with Germany so the players are now
discussing like what they what should be
discussed with other players uh Russia
says good idea that Austria says he'll
be fine as long as you can defend
Sebastopol so Sebastopol is this
territory down to the South you can see
that turkey has a fleet and an Army in
the Black Sea in Armenia next to
Sebastopol and so they could potentially
attack that territory next turn
um
Austria says can you support whole
Sebastopol with Ukraine and Romania I'll
support holdermania Russia says yep I'm
already doing so Austria says awesome
hopefully we can start getting you back
on your feed
so this is an example of the kinds of
conversations that you'll see in a game
of diplomacy
um in this conversation Austria is
actually our bot Cicero so that kind of
gives you a sense of the uh
sophistication of the agent's dialogue
um
okay I'll skip this for okay so uh I
guess I'll go into this I don't want to
take up too much time
um really what makes diplomacy
interesting is that support is key so
here for example
um Budapest and Warsaw the the red and
the purple units both try to move into
Glacier and so since it's a one versus
one they both bounce back and neither
was into the territory uh in the middle
panel you can see Vienna supports
Budapest into Glacier and so now it's a
two versus one and that red unit will
indeed enter galatia and what's really
interesting about diplomacy is that it
doesn't just have to be your own units
that are supporting you it could be
another player's units as well so for
example the green player could support
the red player into Glacier and then
that ready and it would still go in
there
so support is really what the game is
all about negotiating over support
um and so for that reason diplomacy has
this reputation as the game that ruins
friendships
um it's really difficult to have an
alliance with somebody for three or four
hours and then have that
have them backstab you and uh you know
basically just ruin your game
but if you talk to expert diplomacy
players they they view it differently
they say diplomacy is ultimately about
building trust in an environment that
encourages you to not trust anyone
and that's why we decided to work on the
game you know could we make an AI that
is able to build trust with the players
in an environment that encourages them
to not trust anybody
um Can the bot uh like honestly
communicate that it's going to do
something and and evaluate whether
another person is being honest when
they're saying that they're going to do
something
Okay so
why diplomacy it sits in this nice
intersection of reinforcement learning
and planning and also natural language
um there's two perspectives that we can
take on why diplomacy is a really
interesting domain one is the
multi-agent perspective so here
all the previous game AI results
um like chess go poker these have all
been in purely Zero Sum two player
zero-sum domains and in these domains uh
self-play is guaranteed to converge to
an optimal solution basically what this
means is you can start having the bot
play completely from scratch with no
human data and by playing against itself
repeatedly it will eventually converge
to this unbeatable optimal solution
called the Minimax equilibrium
but that result only holds in two player
zerosome games that whole Paradigm only
holds in two player zeros and games
when you go to domains that involve
cooperation in addition to competition
then success requires understanding
human behavior and conventions you can't
just treat the other players like
machines anymore you have to treat them
like humans you have to model
human irrationality human sub-optimality
um one example of this is actually
language like
you can imagine if you were to train a
bot completely from scratch in the game
of diplomacy like the full natural
language version of the game there's no
reason why the bot would learn to
communicate in English it would learn to
communicate in some weird gibberish
robot language and then when you stick
it in a game with six humans it's not
going to be able to cooperate with them
um
so we have to find a way to incorporate
human data and be able to learn how
humans behave in order to succeed in
this game
um okay
there's also the NLP perspective
which is that current language models
are essentially just imitating
human-like text now there's been some
progress with things like rlhf
um but
that's still like not really the way
that humans communicate they communicate
with an intention in Minds right they
come with this intention and then they
communicate with the goal of
communicating that intention and they
understand that others are trying to do
the same
and so there's a question of like can we
move Beyond Chit Chat
uh to grounded intentional dialogue
so Cicero is an AI agent for diplomacy
that integrates high-level strategic
play and open domain dialogue and we
used 50 000 human games of diplomacy
acquired through a partnership with the
website web diplomacy.net
so we entered Cicero in an online
diplomacy League um just to give you the
results up front uh Cicero was not
detected as an AI agent for 40 games
with 82 unique players
um there was one player that mentioned
after the fact that like they kind of
like made a joke about us being a bot
um but they didn't really follow up on
it and nobody else followed up on it and
they later accused somebody else of also
being a bot so we weren't sure how
seriously to take that accusation
um but I think it's safe to say beta
through all 40 games without being
detected as bot
um and then we in fact we told the
players afterwards that it was a bot the
whole time these are the kinds of
responses that we got uh people were
quite surprised pleasantly surprised
fortunately um nobody was was upset with
us but they were quite surprised that
there was a bot that had been playing
this game with them the whole time
so in terms of results Cicero placed in
the top 10 percent of players
um it's a high variance game and so if
you look at
um players that played five or more
games that played second out of 19 and
it achieved more than doubled the
average human score
so I would describe this as a strong
level of human performance I wouldn't go
as far as to say that this is superhuman
by any means
um but it is currently quite a strong
result
now to give you a picture of how Cicero
works
so
the input that we feed into the model is
the board State and the recent action
history that's shown at the top left
here and also the dialogue that it's had
with all the players up until now
so that's going to get fed into a
dialogue conditional action model that's
going to predict what all what Cicero
thinks all the players are going to do
this turn and what they think we will do
this turn
these
um
these lead to what we call Anchor
policies that are then used for planning
um
now planning here
again this is like the part where we
leverage extra compute at test time in
order to get better performance
so essentially we take these initial
predictions of what everybody's going to
do the what are called The Anchor
policies
and we improve upon these predictions uh
using this planning process called
pickle where basically we account for
the fact that players
we'll pick actions that have higher
expected value with higher probability
we're essentially adding this like
rationality prior to all the players to
assume that they're not going to blunder
as often as the model might suggest and
they're going to pick smarter actions
with higher probability than the initial
model might suggest
and what we find is that this actually
gives us a better prediction of what all
the players will do than just relying on
the raw neural net itself
this gives us the action that we
actually play in the game and it also
gives us what we call intense
so intents are an action for ourselves
and an action for the dialogue partner
that we're speaking to
and now we have this dialogue
conditional uh so we have we have this
dialog model that conditions on these
intents so the intents are fed into the
dialogue model along with the board
state in action history and also the
dialogue that we've had so so far and
that dialog model will then generate
candidate messages that
are conditioned on those intents
these candidate messages go through a
series of filters that filter out
nonsense grounding issues and also like
low expected value action low expected
value messages
and ultimately we get out a message to
send to our dialogue partner
now every time we send or receive a
message we will repeat this whole
process
so there's actually a lot that is quite
novel in Cicero um and I'm going to try
to talk about
uh the the contributions as much as
possible I might go through this a
little quickly so we we have time for
questions
um the first one is a controllable
dialogue model by conditions on the game
State and a set of intended actions for
the speaker and the recipient
so I have a question what is the action
space here for the model
um
the action space
for the action prediction model is like
all the actions that you could take in
the game that that a player could take
in the game
for the dialogue model it's like you
know messages that you can send
it so oh
okay so we train what we call an intent
model that predicts what actions people
will take at the end of truthful turns
basically what we're trying to predict
um what are people intending to do when
they communicate a certain message
and um
then we use this to automatically
annotate the data set with basically
what we expect people's intentions were
when they sent that message and we
filter out
um
we filter out as much as possible lies
from the data set so that the
um the text in the data set is annotated
with the truthful
um intention
and then during play Cicero conditions
the dialogue model on the truthful
intention that it intends to take and
the goal then is that the hope then is
that it will uh generate a message
consistent with that intention
and that is then fed into
um into everything else that's that's uh
you know sorry that uh the intentions
that we generate through planning are
fed into the dialogue model
so to give you an example of what this
looks like this gives us a way to
control the dialogue model through a set
of intentions like here
um
we are Cicero's England and pink and
their action is to move to Belgium among
other things
um
and so if we feed this attention into
the dialogue model then the message that
might get generated in something like
England saying to France do you mind
supporting me do you do you mind
supporting Eddie to Belgium
um on the other hand let's say Cicero's
action is the support for answer the
Belgium
um then if you feed that into the
dialogue model then the the message
that's generated might say something
like let me know if you want me to
support you to Belgium otherwise I'll
probably Poe Collins
now what we find is that conditioning
the dialogue model on these intentions
in this way it makes the model more more
controllable but it also leads to higher
quality dialogue with less nonsense
so we found that it led to dialogue that
was more consistent with the state more
consistent with the plan higher quality
lower perplexity and I think the
argument the reasoning for why this is
the case is that we're kind of like
relieving the dialogue model of the
burden of having to come up with
a good strategy we're allowing the
dialogue model to do what it does best
to focus on what it does best which is
dialogue
and we're relieving it of the Strategic
components of the game because we're
feeding that strategy into the dialogue
model
okay so that's one main contribution
this controllable dialogue model that
conditions on on a plan
um the second is a planning engine that
accounts for dialogue and human behavior
so
okay I mentioned that a lot of
previous work on games
was done using self-play
um in two players here are some settings
now the problem with like pure self-play
is that it can learn strong policies but
it doesn't
it doesn't stick with human conventions
and it can't account for dialogue it's
just going to ignore the human data and
the human way of playing if you just do
self-play
so that's one extreme
um The Other Extreme that you can go is
to just do supervised learning on human
data
create this model of how humans play and
then train with those you know imitation
humans
and if you do this you'll end up with a
bot that's consistent with dialogue and
human conventions but it's only as
strong as the training data and we found
that it was actually very easily
manipulable through adversarial dialogue
so for example you can send messages to
it saying like thanks for agreeing to
support me at the Paris and it will
think like well I've only ever seen that
message in my trading data when I've
agreed to support the person of the
Paris and so I guess I'm supporting them
at the Paris the stern even even though
that might be a terrible move for the
bot
so we came up with this algorithm called
pickle that it kind of like is a happy
medium between these these two extremes
um the way Pickle Works is it's
basically trying to it's it's doing
self-play but regularized toward
s sticking to the human imitation policy
so it has a KL penalty for date for
deviating from the human imitation
policy
so we have this parameter Lambda that
controls how easy it is to deviate
um from from the human imitation policy
at Lambda equals zero
it just ignores the human imitation
policy completely and just does pure
self-play
um and so just like do self-play uh as
it from scratch at them to equal zero
all right Lambda equals infinity it's
just playing the human imitation policy
and not doing uh self-play at all
but for intermediate values of Lambda
what we find is that it actually gives
you a good medium between sticking to
human conventions and Performing
strongly
so you can kind of see this Behavior
emerge here
um
sorry there's a question is this similar
to offline RL or also incorporates
exploration so let's say there's
actually a lot of similar work on you
know having a KL penalty
um
and so yes I would say that it's like
very similar to a lot of
um that work it's also been done
actually in Alpha star where they had a
KL penalty
um though that was more about aiding
exploration like using human data to Aid
exploration rather than
um trying to better imitate humans so I
think what's interesting about the
pickle work is that one we find it
imitates humans better than not than
just doing supervised learning alone and
two we are
doing a bit of theory of mind where we
assume that the other players are also
like we're using this as a model for our
behavior
um what what we expect other people to
think our behavior is in addition to
modeling the other players
so it's like a common knowledge
um
common knowledge like uh algorithm that
we're using here
okay so the kind of behavior that you
see from this you can see here let's say
England agrees sorry so let's say we're
in this situation this actually came up
in a real in a real game
um and an inspired figure from our paper
so England and France are fighting
um France is the bot and France asks if
if england is going to disengage
and let's say England says yes I will
move out of English Channel if you head
back to Nao
well we can see that Cicero does in fact
back off
leaves and uh goes to Nao and the
disengagement is successful and so this
shows that the um the bud strategy
really is reflecting the dialogue that
it's had with this other player
um another message that England might
send is something like I'm sorry you've
been fighting me this whole game I can't
trust you that you won't stab me
and so in this case Cicero will continue
its attack on England and you can see
again this is reflective it's it's
changing its Behavior depending on the
dialogue
but you can also have uh this kind of
message where you know England says yes
I'll leave
you know if you move to Munich and haul
into Belgium so these are really bad
moves for Cicero to follow
um and so if you just use if you just
look at the raw policy net
it might actually do this it might
actually do these moves because uh
because England suggested it but because
we're using pickle that incorporates
like you know the expect it counts for
the expected value of different actions
it will actually partially back off but
ignore the suggested boost because it
recognizes that those will leave it very
vulnerable to an attack
um okay I'll skip the slide for time
um
another thing I should say is that
we're not just doing planning we're
actually doing this in a full self-play
reinforcement learning Loop
um and again the goal here is it's
really about modeling humans better than
supervising alone and we found that
doing this self-play reinforcement
learning with pickle allowed us to
better model human behavior
um than just doing imitation learning
uh finally we have an ensemble of
message filtering techniques that
filters both nonsensical and
strategically on sound messages
um so to give you an example of what
these filters look like here one that we
developed is value-based filtering
so
the motivation for this is that when we
when we feed into our dialogue bottle is
a plan for ourselves and for our
speaking partner
um but it's the entire plan that we have
for ourselves and so we might end up
feeding into the dialogue model the fact
that we're going to attack the player
that we're speaking to
now the dialogue model is you know to be
honest kind of dumb and it doesn't
really know
that it shouldn't be telling this player
that they're going to be attacked this
turn
and so you have these messages that
might be sent something like the the
second one shown here where England says
to France we have hostile intentions
towards you you must be wiping the board
please provide a croissant uh so this is
actually like a message that the bot
sent to a player um not to a player it
was uh this was like preliminary testing
and kind of like motivated this whole
approach
um
so we don't want the bot to send these
kinds of messages if it's going to
attack a player we wanted to send
something that's like you know not an
outright lie necessarily but just
something they either not send a message
or send something that's much much more
bland
and so we we filter out these kinds of
messages by looking at the value like
what we do is we generate a bunch of
candidate messages
and then we see if we were to send this
message what is the behavior that we
would expect the other players to take
like what what actions would we expect
them to do after we send this message
and what do they expect we will do after
we send this message
and then we see
what is the expected value of the action
that we intend to take
um given the prediction of what
everybody else is going to do
so if our intention is to attack France
then we can see well if I were to send
this message to France then they're
going to get really defensive and defend
against an attack from us and our attack
is going to be unsuccessful and so
therefore I probably shouldn't send this
message to them
um
and so in this way we can actually
filter out messages that have low
expected value
and we found this this worked
surprisingly well
um dialogue examples I'll go through uh
one just for the sake of time
um so here we have
um
Cicero's France and France is saying uh
France is uh conversing with turkey
who's a human player and they're
debating over who's gonna get Tunis this
territory circled in red
you'd see they both have fleets next to
the territory if they both go for it
neither of them are going to get it and
so they need to work out some sort of
deal
so Fred says I'll work with you but I
need tennis for now turkey says Nope you
gotta let me have it
um France says no I need it and then
France suggests you know you can take
these other territories instead you have
Serbia and Rome to take
um turkey says they're impossible
targets and then Cicero suggests
specific moves
that would allow turkey to capture these
territories so Cicero says Greece Toyota
tyranian
um turkey says you're right good ideas
and then Francis then in the fall you
take Roman Austria collapses and so that
allows turkey to you know make progress
against Austria but conveniently it also
allows uh
France to capture Tunis because uh
turkey will be using those units for
something else
okay so limitations in future directions
um Intel representation is just an
action per player okay so there's a
question of like
the intentions that we're feeding into
the dialogue model is an action that
we're going to take for this turn and
for the next turn for ourselves and for
the other player
but ideally we would have a richer set
of intentions we would be able to like
condition on things like long-term
strategy or style of communication or
like asking questions
um
that is that's one of the limitations of
this approach now of course the Richer
you make the space of intentions
um the more room there is for things to
go wrong and you also have to like then
train the model to be able to handle
these like wider space of intentions
uh there's a question do you think the
dialogue model is learning an internal
model internal World model to be so good
at predicting moves
um no we're
this is this is arguably why we're
conditioning on intentions we're
relieving the dialogue model of having
to come up with a good World model
because we're telling it like these are
the moves that we are planning to take
this turn and these are the moves that
we would like this other player to take
this turn
so we're like
we're able to like
have the world model separate from the
link from the dialogue model but
condition on the output from the world
model
okay another limitation is that Cicero's
value model doesn't condition on
dialogue and so it has a limited
understanding of the long-term effects
of dialogue
um
this greatly limits our ability to
plan what kind of messages we should be
sending
um
and this is actually why we um we always
condition Cicero's dialogue generation
on its truthful intentions
You could argue that there's situations
of diplomacy where you would want to lie
to the other player
um the best players rarely lie but they
they do lie sometimes and
you have to understand the trade-off
between like if you lie you are going to
not it's going to be much harder to work
with this person in the future
um and so you have to make sure that the
value that you're getting positionally
is worth that loss of trust and that
broken relationship
now
because Cicero's value model doesn't
condition on dialogue
it can't really understand this
trade-off and so for this reason we
actually always condition it on its
truthful intentions
now
it is possible to have Cicero's
diabolical condition on dialogue but you
would need way more data and it would
make things much more expensive and so
um we weren't able to do it further for
this spot
and uh finally there's a big question
that I mentioned earlier which is is
there a more General way of scaling
inference time compute to achieve better
performance
the way that we've done planning in
Cicero is I would argue a bit domain
specific um I I think it's like the the
idea of pickle is quite General but I
think that there are potentially more
General ways of doing planning
um
somebody's asking looking forward to the
next two to three years what criteria
criteria will you use to select the next
game to try to conquer
um honestly
like I said we chose diplomacy because
we thought it'd be the hardest game to
make an AI for and I think that that's
true
um I don't think that we're gonna be
working on games anymore because I can't
think of any other game that if we were
to succeed at that it would be truly
impressive
um
and so I think where the research is
going in the future
um is generality
like instead of getting an AI to play
this specific game can we get an AI that
is able to play diplomacy but could also
play go or poker or it could also write
essays and stories and solve math
problems and write theorems
um
I think what we will see
is games serving as benchmarks
for progress but not as
the goal you know it'll be part of the
test set but not part of the training
set and I think that's the way it should
be going forward
um finally I want to add that diplomacy
is an amazing test bed for multi-agent
AI and grounded dialogue
um so if you are interested in these
kinds of domains I highly recommend
taking advantage of the fact that we are
we've open sourced all of our code and
models and the dialogue and action data
is available through a uh what's called
an RFP where you can apply to get access
to the dialogue and and data
okay so thanks for listening um to wrap
up Cicero combined strategic reasoning
and natural language and diplomacy in
place in the top 10 of human players and
the paper is in science and coded models
are publicly available at this URL so
thanks and for the Rainy time I'll take
questions great thanks a lot for your
talk
so we'll also open some questions from
the class
um uh but yeah we've been finished there
are Zoom questions so if anyone has like
some questions or I think you know you
can answer those and yeah there's one
question are you concerned about ai's uh
how competing humans are real world
diplomatic strategic negotiation and
deception tasks
um so like I said we we're not very
focused on Deception even though um you
know arguably deception is a part of the
game of diplomacy
um I
think for diplomatic and strategic
negotiation
I don't like look the way that we've
developed uh Cicero
it's designed to play diplomacy the game
of diplomacy specifically and you can't
use it out of the box for other tasks
um that said I do think that the
techniques are quite
General
um and so hopefully others can build on
that and to be able to do uh different
things and I think it is you know
entirely possible that over the next
several years you will see this entering
uh into real world negotiations uh much
more often I actually think that
diplomacy is a big step towards real
world applicability compared to uh
breakthroughs and games like go and
poker
um because because now your action Space
is really like the space of natural
language and you have to model human
behavior
do you think in the future we could
appoint AI to the U.N console
uh hopefully hopefully only if it does
better than humans um but that would be
very interesting to see
great I'm also curious like uh what
What's like the future things that
you're working on in this direction like
do you think you can do something like a
couple zero where you just like take
this take this like pitted model and
then major speak in Excel play uh or
like what's what sort of featured
actions are you thinking for improving
this sort of box
I think the future directions are really
focused around generality
um like I think one of the big insights
of diploma of Cicero is like this
ability to leverage planning to get
better performance with like uh with
language models and in this strategic
domain
um
I think there's a lot of opportunity to
do that sort of thing in a broader space
of domains I mean you look at language
models today and they do token by token
prediction
um
and I think there's a big opportunity to
go beyond that so that's what I'm
excited to look into I'm also curious
like I didn't understand exact details
how using planning or Monte Carlo
research with your uh like the models
that you have
research
is a very good heuristic but it's a
heuristic that is
particularly useful for deterministic
perfect information games
um
and I think in order to like have a
truly general form of planning we need
to go more abstract than monster College
research we use this algorithm called
pickle
um based on a regret minimization
algorithm I don't really want to go into
the details of it because it's not that
important for the class
um but the idea is like it is this
iterative algorithm that will gradually
refine the prediction of what
everybody's going to do and get better
and better predictions the more
iterations that you run
similar to search
yep
got it yeah
um
so yeah my question is like when we were
talking about gender like the ability
how does the communication between
different modules of the model look like
and particularly when we're talking
about the dialogue model
like how do you send information from
the policy Network to the dialogue model
and in the future if you have a model
that's good at different tasks are we
going to have like a really big policy
net that learns all of them or like
separate language modules for all of
them like how do you break it down
so we actually convert the policy like
the action for ourselves and for our
dialogue partner into uh a string
natural language string and just speed
that into the dialog model along with
all the dialogue that it's had so far so
it's just all text in text out
um
and and that that works great
um and then what was the second part of
your question
something like uh are we just gonna have
like one giant policy net trend on
everything
yeah it was like so if you're only using
text first doesn't it limit the model
and if you're using this for different
uh games like are you thinking like what
you say in the future you will work on
generalizability are you thinking about
a big policy Network that is trained on
separate games or is able to do like
understand different games at the same
time or do we have like separate policy
networks for different games
yeah and yeah like doesn't dislike uh
text interface limit the model in terms
of communication like if you're using
vectors it might like
yeah it might be the bottom link
um I mean I I think ideally you go in
this direction where you have like you
know a foundational model that works for
pretty much everything
um does text I mean certainly uh just
like a text and text out that like when
it's what you can do
um excuse communication but hopefully we
get beyond that
um I think it's a reasonable choice for
now
thank you
now I can get more zoom questions okay
so there's a question in the chat uh I'd
love to hear your speculation on the
future for instance we've seen some
startups that are fine-tuning llms to be
biased uh or experts in say subject
experts okay why
um
this seems like a pretty uh general
question
uh
I don't have strong opinions on this
um
I yeah I mean
like I'm not I'm not too um
I'm not too focused myself on you know
fine-tuning language models to specific
tasks
um
I think the direction that I'm much more
interested in going forward is you know
like the more General forms of planning
so I don't think I can really comment on
you know how do you
tune these language models
um in these ways
so what sort of planning uh methods are
you like interested in looking at like
like MCTS is one
um so let me so I got to step out for
just one second
um got the switch rooms excuse me
okay never mind uh we're all good uh
sorry what was the question oh yes I was
thinking I was just asking like what
sort of planning algorithms do you think
are very interesting
so you think we have like so many
options like we have like Planet kind of
stuff or Auto there's like mcps there's
like the the work you did with sister so
what do you think are the most
interesting algorithms that you think
will scale well uh can generalize
well I think that's the big question
that a lot of people are trying to
figure out today and um it's it's not
really clear what the answer is
um I mean I think you know you look at
some of the Chain of Thought and
I think there's a lot of limitations to
Chain of Thought
um and I think that it should be
possible to do a lot better but it is
really impressive to see just how
general of an approach it is
um
and so I think it would be nice to see
to see things that are General in that
in that way um but hopefully able to
achieve better performance
got it
awesome
also will you still like sister is like
a encoder decoder model uh in a sense it
encodes the world and then you have the
dialogue model which is time to record
it
uh it was an encoder decoder model yes
um I don't think that that's necessarily
the right choice
um I I but that's what we used
any questions
okay I think yeah you're mostly good
but yeah thanks a lot
well yeah I hope you all enjoyed it and
if there are any questions feel free to
email me reach out I'm happy to happy to
chat